the film opens on the bustling streets
of Pari with the city preparing to
celebrate Bastille Day Out of Nowhere a
naked woman appears there capturing
everyone's attention among the crowd
there is Michael Mason a clever American
con man with a knack for pickpocketing
let's see him pick up pockets that's
naked seeing everyone distracted he
definitely steals Wallace cell phones
and various belongings from people later
we get to know that the woman is
actually Michael's accomplice and he had
paid her 300 Euros to create this
diversion in the next scene we are
introduced to CIA agent Sean Breyer a
seasoned operative who finds himself in
trouble after a recent Mission he was
working on gozerai he's questioned and
interrogated about the failure by his
seniors and is taunted for not being
able to save one of his colleagues
however Sean defends himself claiming he
calculates the risks and prioritizes
completing the mission the scene then
shifts to another character Jean a man
with malicious intentions he inserts an
explosive device inside a teddy bear and
instructs his girlfriend Zoe to
discreetly place it in an off
French nationalist party headquarters
Zoe initially hesitates apprehensive
about the potential danger to innocent
lives but Gene's persuasion wins are
over and she decides to proceed with the
task the plan is to send a threatening
message but the office is supposed to be
empty at the time of the explosion
meanwhile Michael wastes no time and
promptly sells the stolen items to a
shady figure named Baba in return for
his loot he receives a generous reward
of 900 euros on the other hand Zoe
arrives at the destined location
carrying the teddy bear in her handbag
she plants it as suggested but at the
same time some people enter the office
unexpectedly this is enough to change
Zoe's mind so she decides to abort the
mission and takes the handbag with her
outside Michael is watching her as she
talks anxiously to her boyfriend over
the phone assuming that she has
something very precious in her bag he
steals it and runs away unbeknownst to
Michael the handbag contains the teddy
bear bomb along with Zoe's cell phone
after a while Gene calls Zoe again and
Michael picks it up upon here hearing a
man's voice Michael instinctively hangs
up and oblivious to the imminent danger
leaves the bag on the side of the road
tragically as he walks away up a couple
of steps the bomb detonates resulting in
the loss of four innocent lives because
of the explosion chaos insists and
Michael flees the scene though the
explosion does not occur at the intended
location its impact sends shock waves
through the city meanwhile Rafi The
Mastermind behind the blast issues a
menacing threat to the French government
warning of further attacks within the
next 36 hours in Paris journalists flock
to question Mr Victor the head of French
intelligence about the city's safety
after the bombing and the threat in
reply Victor assures them that the
perpetrators will be caught soon and
promises that the Bastille Day Parade
will continue as planned next the CIA
surveillance unit receives Michael's
photo from a security camera and sends
it to both the CIA and Interpol soon
they find out that Michael is a
pickpocketer and has a troubled past
born in Las Vegas to a casino boss
and a realtor mother they also get to
know that his father's gambling debts
LED Michael to drop out of school and
turn to fraud to survive eventually
ending up in France Sean is then
assigned with the mission to secretly
arrest Michael at his apartment and hand
him over to the French government on the
other hand Michael is at his apartment
worried into looking through the news
channels right then he notices his
picture being broadcasted on TV as a
wanted criminal responsible for the Bomb
Blast at the same time he senses the
authorities closing in on him so he
frantically tries to flee from there
unfortunately Sean notices him running
away and a lengthy Chase ensues Michael
tries his best to evade the veteran
operative but in the end he's eventually
caught afterward he is brought to an
interrogation room and asked about his
sole purpose for the bombing Michael
truthfully confesses that he threw the
bag but it didn't belong to him he had
actually stolen it from a woman wearing
a blonde wig named Zoe he also hands
over Zoe's mobile phone that he stole
before the explosion Sean is a bit
skeptical about the story so to test his
skills he asks Michael to pickpocket his
wallet as expected the con man does it
successfully without even breaking a
sweat look boobs got it at Jean's house
Zoe is distressed believing that she
caused the deaths of four innocent
people in the bombing Gene consoles Zoe
and suggests she leaves Paris mentioning
that his boss will not leave her alive
meanwhile Rafi and his men decide to go
to Jean's house to find Zoe they trace
her phone's signal unaware that the
phone is actually with Sean and Michael
when Rafi arrives at the location
disguised as a mailman Sean senses
trouble and prepares for confrontation
however the bad guys easily overpower
him and beat him up during the chaos
Michael also manages to escape soon Rafi
and his men realize that they have
arrived at the wrong house so they run
away from the scene Sean then reports to
his senior Tom and decides to search for
Zoe to uncover the larger truth behind
the incident elsewhere in his office
Victor is informed about the location of
the bomb manufacturers after which he
demands to meet the head of a special
police force called rapid shun he is
introduced to the commander of Rapid who
turns out to be none other than Rafi
right then they receive urgent Intel
about a potential terrorist threat in an
Arabian immigrant settlement without
delay Rafi and his rapid team rushed to
the location to investigate upon arrival
the team conducts a Swift and forceful
raid on the settlement in a disturbing
turn of events one of the officers
discreetly plants a bomb on the premises
to frame the innocent immigrants and
create a false report tragically all the
immigrants are apprehended and the blame
for the bombing falls on them while the
real culprit Michael remains a fugitive
and an elsewhere Michael unaware
of where to seek Refuge goes to his
client Baba a supposed friend initially
Baba listens to his problem and offers
them a place to live but after a while
he backstabs him and locks him in a room
turns out baba met with the officials
and was enticed by the government's
promise of providing his family with
French citizenships in return for his
help in capturing Michael after a while
Rafi and his team arrive at the building
and begin searching for desperate to
escape Michael finds a small crack in
the wall and hides there evading
detection as Rafi and his teams surround
the building he waits for the perfect
moment to make a run for his life
eventually he seizes his chance and
dashes outside unaware that a sniper has
him in his sights however just before
the sniper can take a fatal shot Sean
arrives in the nick of time and rescues
my God meanwhile Zoe manages to reach
her friend's Hideout seeking safety from
the dangerous situation later that day
Sean and Michael gather Intel on Zoe's
whereabouts and set out to find her
unfortunately when they reach The
Hideout and inquire with Zoe's friends
about her they are attacked to make
matters worse the goons set fire to
Sean's car before running away next in
their quest to track down Zoe's
associates they come up with a plan Sean
extracts Zoe's friends Paul's
information from her phone and Michael
with his expert pickpocketing skills
infiltrates Paul's workplace and manages
to obtain his ID card with the
information from the ID card they track
Paul's House's location and when they
visit there find Zoe hiding inside Sean
immediately confronts her and Under
Pressure she confesses that her
boyfriend Jean ordered her to carry out
the bombing despite her refusal she also
mentions that the bomb was meant as a
form of attack against fascism but when
she realized innocent lives were at risk
she decided to abandon the mission
following this the three set out to
confront Gene at his apartment but
encounter Rafi along the way fortunately
they narrowly evade his pursuit in
another part of the city a massive
anti-fascist demonstration erupts
following an unprovoked attack on Arab
immigrants in a mosque online protests
gain momentum as people rally to support
the movement however little do they know
that the chaos is being orchestrated by
Rafi and corrupt police officers in
reality rafi's men spread a fake video
of police torturing Arab demonstrators
to escalate tensions meanwhile when Sean
Zoe and Michael reached Gene's apartment
they are shocked to discover that he has
been killed by Rafi Sean identifies his
tattoo and on searching around the house
he finds an ID it reveals the gene was
part of the rapid unit this is when it
finally Dawns on Sean that Rafi and his
men have been posing as police officers
and creating chaos wasting no time he
immediately reports this shocking
Revelation to his supervisor Karen and
exposes the corrupt rapid squad's
involvement in the bombing and framing
of innocent immigrants Karen however
suggests he stay away from Rapid and
decides to hand over the case to French
intelligence since it is beyond the
cia's jurisdiction she then arranges a
meeting with Victor to expose him to the
truth unfortunately after Karen provides
him with the information Victor shoots
her to death and reveals himself as The
Mastermind behind the entire incident he
mentions that he orchestrated the
bombings and threats to incriminate Arab
immigrants and plunge the city into
chaos afterward Victor orders his men
including Rafi to capture Sean Zoe and
Michael and eliminate them secretly but
when the rapid Squad arrives at the
location the trio somehow manages to
escape meanwhile online demonstrators
gather millions of supporters
unknowingly playing into Victor's Grand
scheme in the next scene Victor
manipulates public perception with a
press conference and falsely promises
maximum security measures he also orders
rapid to guard the National Bank Sean
realizing that Karen is dead reports of
Victor's true intentions to his senior
officer Tom however Tom is skeptical due
to Victor's position as the head of
French intelligence determined to stop
Victor's plot Sean takes matters into
his own hands and decides to secure the
bank himself he leaves Michael and Zoe
in the van and enters the bank alone
disguised as a police officer as soon as
he walks in Sean takes down some guards
at the entrance and equips himself with
their weapons inside the building he
faces multiple challenges as the police
have complete control of the security
system and are currently disabling all
alarms and cameras at the same time Rafi
and his colleague Kristoff Target a
digital money Reserve worth 500 million
euros intending to steal it using a
flash drive as Sean's disguise is
discovered after he eliminates a couple
of officers the rapid team surrounds him
and begins firing at him outside side
with the firing going on Zoe and Michael
learn that Sean is in trouble and decide
to assist him they walk into the crowd
and incite a riot using the chaos to
breach the police barricade with this
distraction Sean manages to fight off
the police officers and eliminate them
he then walks towards the Vault and
confronts Rafi who has the flash drive
containing the stolen money after this
an intense gunfight ensues between the
two parties Sean manages to incapacitate
Kristoff but Rafi escapes to a locked
room from there he contacts Victor and
requests to rescue him from the
situation however to his dismay Victor
refuses to do so and in response Rafi
threatens to expose his plants if he
gets caught on the other hand Sean
contacts Michael and urges him to steal
the flash drive from Rafi obeying the
order Michael cleverly collides with
Rafi while he is walking out and pulls
the flash drive from his pocket however
the latter soon finds out about it
because there was no naked lady to
distract his attention so he takes Zoe
hostage and threatens to harm her unless
Michael Returns the flash drive but
right then the cops present at the scene
shoot Rafi and kill him on the spot
turns out Victor ordered the
assassination as he feared Rafi would
expose his wrongdoings in the aftermath
Victor is hailed as a hero for exposing
the corrupt police Syndicate while
Michael remains a wanted fugitive Victor
then seeks Baba's help to track down
Michael's whereabouts as he is desperate
for the flash drive worth 500 million in
digital currency Baba doesn't want to
deceive his friend again but when the
cunning Victor threatens him he spreads
false news about a high-paying buyer for
the flash drive in the next scene
Michael falls into Victor's trap and
goes to meet him at a church believing
he is the supposed flash drive buyer as
the two come face to face Victor offers
him money and a passport to leave the
country in exchange for the flash drive
surprisingly Michael accepts his offer
and hands over the drive however once
Victor gets what he wants he points a
gun at Michael planning to eliminate him
as a witness what he doesn't know is
that Michael Sean and the police have
set a trap to get his confession and
take him under control the movie then
ends with Victor getting arrested and
his Sinister plot being exposed
Michael's cunning Maneuvers and Sean's
intelligence help bring Victor to
Justice and the truth prevails subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching